it's what we call a train and bike it's
the golden combination because you can
get anywhere you want at any time
this is Esther a Dutch cycling
campaigner she's commuting home from a
day in the office in Utrecht to get to
the station she's using the train
operators bike sharing scheme I think
what makes the Dutch system unique is
that you can combine your own personal
bike with this shared bike so you don't
have to take your bike into the train
and this is much more comfortable for
both passengers and cyclists
the European Parliament is calling for
an EU strategy to get more people on
bikes and it's exactly this kind of
scheme that it wants to encourage is
[Music]
parliaments once to double the number of
kilometers cycled by 2030 this means
better cycling infrastructure like
dedicated bike Lanes secure bike parks
and more integration with other modes of
Transport like in Utrecht rural cycling
should be supported too by speeding up
the development of cycle highways and
the 17 routes on the eurovelo network
MEPS want cycling to improve our health
and help reduce congestion and pollution
all parts of the eu's green transition
Europe cycling industry and Battery
manufacturers should also be supported
boosting access to Affordable made in
Europe bicycles and e-bikes to get the
wheels rolling parliament's calling for
2024 to be designated the European year
of cycling
foreign
[Music]